like I said before we got started just
want to say I've been a fan for perhaps
close to 30 years so um it's pretty cool
to be able
to talk uh there's going to be people
out there I like throwing some
curveballs at the beginning there going
to be people out there that have never
heard a song by Weezer so I am curious
if someone has never heard anything by
Weezer what is the first thing you'd
like them listening to and why well I
find it hard to believe I think I think
a lot of people think they've never
heard a song by Weezer but then when you
play him Island in the Sun or Beverly
Hills or something they're like oh yeah
I've heard Weezer but yeah start there
why not Island in the Sun closing on a
billion streams it's such a crazy
number yeah what's our latest single
rivers from last
record our last record didn't have a
single uh maybe uh
what was our last record there's so many
so many of them we had a we had a cover
of Africa that got pretty big on the
radio okay okay like okay we had black
and then and then van
Weezer I would have somebody Listen to I
know what I'm thinking of all my
favorite songs my one of my favorite
records of ours is is our okay human
record I'd like them hear
we put down the electric guitars and
played played along with an orchestra so
that was a real treat for
us uh you guys have been able to tour
the planet and I'm just curious and and
perform for all sorts of people when was
the last time you guys were actually
nervous before stepping on stage to
perform for someone or a group uh well I
was nervous at the at the shoot for for
this movie Family switch you know that
is a good question because at some point
far as playing like a Weezer set the
nerves kind of for me just sort of uh
vanished and I don't know I can't
pinpoint when exactly that was but a lot
of it has to do with preparation and
being prepared um and also knowing the
material so well so it is kind of also
good to have new material and do things
that
um don't necessarily make you nervous
but make you excited and that's kind of
the goal to staying like you know we're
keeping it fresh for yourself I was
going to say I think I think I was
nervous a few months ago we opened for
kiss at their last show ever in
Australia and they're like my childhood
Heroes and I walked out on stage and you
know it's this massive Stadium filled
with kiss fans and of course everyone in
the audience has the kiss makeup so it
looked like like thousands of Jean
Simmons and Paul Stanley staring back at
me uh as I was trying to sing Weezer
songs it was pretty nerve-wracking I I
actually went to a Premiere in Hollywood
and I was seated next to Jean and his
family and it took everything in my
heart to just not talk to them about
kiss you know because Jean was right
next to me and I was like you know it's
Jean
Simmons
yeah yeah those are the real rock stars
there I mean for real uh so Rivers you
mentioned you were a little nervous you
actually have like real dialogue and
family switch not just a word or even
one sentence like real dialogue so how
nervous were you before stepping on set
to do something like that which is
definitely not in your normal wheelhouse
yeah um actually it really helped to
have Brian there because he's been
taking acting lessons and I could see
how he was reparing preparing and uh he
would give me
um help from time to time like this is
this is what we should do this is what
you should think about and it give me a
lot a lot of reassurance as I was I
don't remember saying any of that stuff
but uh I do remember thinking the
training that I've had over you know
started maybe in 2017 and then through
Zoom etc etc um going okay you You'
you've this is not
uh this is not over you know past you or
whatever this something that you can
handle just it's just Ed Helms you know
like just just just just make him the
focus of your attention I think I might
have said something like that and
everything will be fine RI you know the
movie is not about us it's about the
situation it's about the story and and
MCG was uh the the director was so easy
to work with and made us feel so um
comfortable in this this world where we
really only had what's called sides we
didn't have the script to sort of
understand like where we fit fit in and
where these lines belong because it's a
it is a comedy and uh we said
actually there was a whole scene that
got cut out maybe a DVD version will
have that scene and uh there are many
lines that we actually said that got cut
out as well so it was all about for them
um making it work with the pacing of the
movie so that's why everything kind of
was like you know and it's
it's it's a light harded and
all-inclusive family Christmas movie oh
that also it's a body swap movie which
is just it's a body movie yeah which to
me it was the original uh jod Foster
Freaky Friday um was the I saw it in the
theater uh kind of um you know blew me
away how fun it was and then watching it
again as adult you realize oh my God the
mother was only about 20 years old
and can write a skateboard that's a
whole other thing uh I actually want to
ask you guys a body swap question but I
want to I want to pull it into rock into
you know music which is if you guys
could switch places switch bodies with
any previous person in the music
industry uh who would you switch places
with and why uh I would like pav pavati
is that his name uh yeah they have a
voice that just was filled up a room I'd
like to know what that feels like
yeah yeah maybe Josh groin and that
could be Sweeney Todd on Broadway I
think that'd be
cool um I am curious Rivers have you
ever thought about um scoring or um like
a TV show or a movie or has the band
been ever asked to score a film a lot
like with music or maybe the way Queen
did uh um you know Flash Gordon or
Highlander that that would be
cool uh yeah we' certainly been asked
I'm sure about no nobody's asked the
band I I I was asked to do a few songs
for uh for a movie that came out was it
last
year um oh yeah that was that was cool
movie songwriter right yeah it was
really great it was um uh the guy who
plays Frasier kelse
Kelsey gramar yeah and this girl that
was on a show called The Affair the
daughter from the affair I can't
remember her name but she's quite pretty
but it was a very good show very space
between and uh it was really cool
because it was about a singer songwriter
like in
the James Taylor or like Elliot Smith
fer and so I got to like step into this
other role and write from a completely
different perspective like very acoustic
introspective and at first it it was
hard and I just kind of sent them
basically Weezer songs and the music
director was like no no and um
eventually I got it and it was super
fun so you can find that on Spotify I
know that you guys have a lot of
unreleased songs do you think you have
more than what's in the prince Vault or
do you think Prince has you beat that's
a good question
I I think we have more because we're
closer you know we're closer to the
digital era and so I think more of my
life has been recorded into a cell phone
and voice notes like I record everything
and it's just an endless supply I'm just
imagining uh do you guys think you have
a thousand or even 2,000 unrelease songs
is it like a level like that or do you
think like songs that if you you could
actually push play
and it's a full song or is it a lot of
like Snippets and ideas but not fully
fledged compositions well I have a
website called wifi. web. apppp and
they're they're all they're all up there
at least up through like
2018 and there's about
3500 now a lot of those are exactly what
you describe Snippets or like alternate
versions of another song um so I don't
know I'd
say yeah there's got to be at least a
thousand unique songs have you guys
thought about doing I I have to want to
interject I have an app that Rivers made
wait Brian don't don't tell anybody
about that sorry I don't have an app
that Rivers made I
was I was more said this not not to rub
that in for all his Weezer fans I wish
they didn't have a app that Weezer
didn't we Rivers didn't make but just to
say that this guy knows code well enough
to make an app like that's crazy I won't
get you in any trouble I'll switch to
something else we are approaching the
30th anniversary of The Blue Album which
is May of next year uh I know that you
guys were thinking about or are thinking
about doing something cool for the 30th
anniversary maybe it's a box set maybe
it's I don't know actually what you're
doing so do you know what you're doing
for the 30th Anniversary we're we're uh
we're putting the ideas together it's
like it feels like the interest and the
passion for that album is just off the
scale so I know was the 20th anniversary
I didn't I didn't do anything I was like
I don't care but it's just you can't
ignore it this time it's just this tital
wave of of passion so we are going to
give it its due respect and come out
with a a really
amazing deluxe package with a bunch of
additional material and of course we got
a do some kind of Epic tour that's what
I was going to ask you I looked on your
the website last night just to see your
touring schedule of next year and I know
you're playing in Oklahoma I think on
the 29th of December and then you're
doing a tour next summer but is there
something more for the blue album that
you're thinking about because it's the
30th Anniversary yeah I think you I
think this the public tour dates cut off
in June and then there's like this very
suspicious blank space in our calendar
for the months after that so I'd keep
your eye on that
exactly um four fans uh I am curious if
you are planning on releasing new music
anytime soon perhaps next year or what
is what have you guys been working on if
anything well yeah we're we're always
working we just had a big listening
session at my house all the guys came
over played them a bunch of demos and uh
they gave me their thoughts and feedback
and it's very exciting then we all went
and played pickle ball so if I only I
had an app that had all these songs but
I
don't but all I know is at listening
party I was stoked what I was hearing I
think I think Weezer fans are going to
be stoked and I think even non- Weezer
fans people maybe have not even heard of
Weezer are gonna going to know of us
finally these songs are great this is
the album Number 20 yeah I I complete
it's almost a shame it's the 30th
Anniversary because I want people to
hear these new songs but we we might be
um through uh you
know just the laws of the universe have
to do something for the 30th because it
is a big deal yeah our manager said the
problem is if you put out a new album at
the same time as your 30th anniversary
celebration of your first album nobody's
going to pay attention to the new one it
just gets lost I want to know what
metric like somebody like figured that
out because how many bands are around
that long that have a that have new
music to put out that same year I bet
very few well I know one green day is
doing it right now oh okay yeah so we're
kind of watching to see what happens to
them our our brother's from another Punk
world I actually understand where your
manager's coming from and think that it
makes sense as much as I want to hear
new Weezer music um but that's just me
just speaking but um I'm almost out of
time and I have two questions I really
want to ask you guys okay um so I really
enjoy do you know the band Coheed and uh
Cambria yeah so I really enjoyed their
song Jesse's Girl to with Rick
Springfield like it's very catchy and
it's different than what they've done
and they made a sequel song with the
original guide to some you know it was a
really good song so I wanted to know if
you guys ever thought about essentially
writing a sequel to to a popular song
either that you've done or somebody else
has
done is it I wish I had Jesse's Girl
to no no it it's like liter it's you
should after this conversation listen to
it on Spotify or wherever it's catchy as
it doesn't make sense how good it
is and he did it with they did it with
Rick Springfield it's like it's really
like a sequel to the song 30 years later
amazing I'll check that out yes we do
have a sequel It's called CEO and it's
it's going to be on our next album it's
it's a sequel to The Sweater song it's
totally meta and mind-bending are you
joking or being completely serious
completely serious back Me Up Brian yeah
I don't know if am I allowed uh yeah uh
as of now there was a song called
CEO I cannot believe that that that my
question led to that which is I mean
Sweater song is one of my all-time
favorites so I can't wait to hear it um
and the other thing I really wanted to
ask you guys obviously AI is something
that everyone is talking about in the
movie industry and in the TV industry
with actors but it's also a very
significant thing with the music
industry and I wanted to know what you
guys both think about Ai and uh how AI
might affect the music industry going
forward you mean for creators or for the
business side I think for everything
because you know people could now
essentially Maybe I'm Wrong about this
but they could go in and say want AI to
create a song like Weezer and you know
they can sort of do that with I want
that that's what we've been trying to do
for 30 years make my job
easier no but but I am I am curious what
you guys think about uh Ai and and its
place in the music industry and what
could possibly happen well on the
business side I have no idea I have no
idea how the business works anymore but
I'm sure it's going to have a big impact
I'm just the wrong person to ask
on the creative side so far it's been
just a brilliant tool and I'm having a
lot of fun using it uh when we put out
our last record I before it came out I
put up My My lyrics to one of our songs
and I I had chat GPT write a song with
the same title and I posted them both on
Twitter and said which do you think is
the real
Weezer um and I won the battle on that
day but uh I think the day is coming
where we're going to get beat
so we'll see I think we'll always need a
human element in music and I
don't you know a lot there's stuff I'm
hearing like wow I don't even is this
music uh I feel obsolete but um and I'm
sure it'll even get worse with ch I mean
so sorry AI but and that being
said there's things we can do that they
AI will never be able to do so not too
concerned and I feel like I like music
that feels real and so far it hasn't
hasn't uh tricked me yet yeah my my big
thing what I've talked about with a lot
of people is the fact that right now
it's like AI is like the first iPhone
and what I'm afraid about and what I
think people are nervous about is what
it's going to be like when you get to
the iPhone 14 with AI you know and or
iPhone 15 and how much more advanced it
is but conversation for another day
gentlemen I could ask you a thousand
other questions but I am already it'll
have face recognition
oh it's going to be scary but River just
already demonstrated with chat gbt that
it you know it's in its infancy with
being able to write a Weezer song but in
10 years we have fun with it on tour
like write a country song in the vein of
you know some crazy idea and and and
we'll laugh our ass off about the lyrics
that come out um it is what it is yeah
completely but listen uh gentlemen I
really want to thank you for your time
like I said I have a thousand other
questions but I'm out of
time